oh great you know i thought about
getting up here never thought about
getting down
another
simple exercise
create a juxtaposition
create a difference a clear
distinction
between sun
and clouds
between essence and
expression
sun being
essence
distorted expressions
so when
the expression
is bouncing
between thought clouds
emotions beliefs
the contracted feeling of needing to be
seen
wanting to be validated by other people
needing to
force your point of view into
conversations
this is when the expression
of consciousness of awareness of that
sunlight
is cloudy and
dark
because it's a separate egoic entity
that wants to try to extract peace and
happiness from other
separate egoic entities that it has no
relationship to
now there's a healthy expression as well
which we'll talk about in a moment but
let's talk about the sun
light itself so the sun light itself
is the essence it is pure bare empty
consciousness awareness without its
coloration of a costume
so what i share with you is
consciousness is awareness
and then this individuated unit gets the
costume of
atlas and your individuated unit gets a
different
costume
but what is at the essence underlying
the costumes
is the same so in this exercise
what we do is we tap deeper and deeper
inward into the sunlight
essence of what we truly are and not so
much the expression
of the atlas costume and the all the
other costumes
and the dark thought clouds versus the
ones that are spontaneous
manifestations from god from the one
intelligence
that are then in pure service to
creation
so that would be an example of a white
expression so a dark expression
is one that's egoic contracted based on
separation based on lack
not even aware of the chain of thinking
between thought clouds whereas the white
expression is the pure expression
it's the expression that comes from a
state of god realization
and when you know yourself as the one
intelligence when you know yourself
as
the infinite mystery expressing itself
you already know yourself to be 100
whole full already
worthy already validated already seen
and you don't try and extract
and so then what you do is you simply
radiate like the sun
so this is when you know the true
essence
you then just radiate like the sun
unconditional love
peace joy bliss harmony
[Music]
pure service in shepherding
the further awakening
of the creation
humans are gifted with the
self-awareness to be able to turn
inward and understand the essence of
consciousness of awareness
of god of the infinite mystery but we're
so
infatuated with the expression in this
juxtaposition
we're so infatuated with the different
costumes and we're so infatuated with
the different thoughts
and emotions and beliefs and
perspectives and wanting to
be seen and be validated and be worthy
that we get lost in all of the dark
egoic separation
processes and that's where spirituality
is birthed
spirituality is simply the realignment
to the one heart to the one infinite
mystery that we
are to god and that's where the turn
inward comes just like in the parable of
the prodigal son
and so make this juxtaposition really
simple when you turn inward you're
tapped into the essence you're tapped
into the sun
you're tapped into that unconditional
radiant love light
serving the creation and then when
you're expressing
make the juxtaposition in the expression
between
the dark egoic separation
unworthy trying to extract peace and
happiness
versus the white pure divine
spontaneous expression that comes
directly
from the essence of god serving
shepherding unconditional love peace joy
harmony bliss equanimity
another fun exercise
thanks for tuning in
really glad we were able to shoot this
at the beautiful mount
san jacinto near
palm springs california
infinite love peace
you